commune du morne-rouge les yeux rivés
sur l'écran de sa télé ventura varane et
son fils rudy sont à l'affût de la
moindre information sur l'équipe de
france mais leur intérêt pour l'équipe
nationale est surtout motivé par la
présence dans le onze des bleus de
membres de la famille raphaël varane
quant aux inquiétudes évoquées par une
certaine presse sur son entente en
charnière centrale avec le barcelonais
entity voilà ce qu'ils en pensent c'est
quelqu'un de facile à vivre donc quel
que soit le jour il à ses côtés donc un
problème c'est un joueur c'est 4 sur les
épaules qui est un bon en réunion et qui
s'affirme et c'est ce qui aurait permis
au jeune footballeur de s'imposer au rc
lens de la halle de nouveau avant
d'évoluer en équipe première
ses qualités hors norme feront du
défenseur l'un des protégés de zinedine
zidane
instigateur de sa venue au real madrid
le martiniquais était à cette époque
âgé de 18 ans donc
il a été tout de suite européen lors des
stages il ya toutes été opéré son père
gaston sa mère à nous c'est à se voiler
sa rafale et là c'est de son père que le
défenseur des bleus tient ses origines
martiniquaises
l'aîné des barran quitte le morne rouge
en 1972 pour aller chercher du travail
en france à lille il sera agent
hospitalier et fera trois enfants avec
une enseignante de raphaël slama
ok je sors plus cela c'est celui de
vannes
quand la dernier lève de son banc
l'an dernier c'était la 12e
celle ci au mondial-2014 france coaxiaux
et salua si je la porte avec mon école
rudy le petit cousin de martinique n'a
que rêve suivre que la carrière de
raphaël son idole à 14 ans il s'entraîne
d'arrache-pied avec le club de sa
commune depuis la russie le jeune homme
ne cesse sur son jeu vidéo de refaire le
match france australie
une manière peut être de conjurer le
sort
en tout cas ici au mans ne rouge c'est
la france qui gagne